so one of the things you want to
jettison are things that you're not
aware of you got clutter around your
house you've got clutter inside your
your own house your internal house your
body
[Music]
I want to tune in to Facebook we have a
question here from Dave I am five foot
six and 132 pounds yet I still have a
significant amount of belly fat and fat
around my face how do I minimize the
excess fat without trying to go stupidly
low in actual weight I can't believe
that in my mid-40s I need to be below
130 pounds now Dr Sean I know you'll
probably address this a little bit
differently I'm going to put a few
things here on the screen first first I
want to show image number two here this
is you and this is a picture of your
face at age 48 and then a picture of you
at age 59 here and what we see on the
screen is an appreciable difference a
much healthier person on the right side
even though two things a you're
considerably older in this picture even
though you don't look older in this
picture but also you actually weigh more
and it seems to me what we often do is
we are measuring the wrong things you
want to lose weight cut off your leg and
you'll instantly walk out well I guess
you'll hop out of here weighing less but
Dr Sean talk to me about this image and
also image three we've got something
else where you uh we we can see an
appreciable difference in in how you've
changed personally yeah that's great so
you know minimizing uh What uh what is
really uh important so the MRI is sort
of like this magical looking class it
allows you to focus and help you make
decisions like what you can jet Us in
and what you should be building so I
love the MRI for being able to do that
so one of the things you want to
jettison are things that you're not
aware of you got clutter around your
house you got clutter inside your your
own house your internal house your body
but you don't know about it unless you
get scanned to see it so the MRI allows
you to see this very dangerous substance
visceral fat and one of the places it
manifests actually is in your face so
it's one of the most noticeable all
places but it manifests throughout the
body so right up front you can see the
change in my face where I'm 48 I have a
lot of inflammation even though I
weighed less during the interval between
those two photographs I jettison
dangerous inflammatory visceral fat and
you can see it in my face so I got a
leaner face on my image to the right and
then the third image you can see this
profile lateral view you can see the
impact of that visceral fat once it
leaves so interestingly one of the
manifestations of visceral fat is it
degrades your muscle performance so it
helps to first of all you lose muscle
mass so with a condition called
sarcopenia or medical Frailty we start
losing our valuable good stuff in our
house you know your muscle so that one
you want to retain so when you when you
want to have a more minimalist lifestyle
you gotta ask what really is important
and hold on to that stuff and what isn't
important you you become aware of you
get rid of so muscle is really good and
it's not just the amount of muscle but
how well it's performing so in that
first image on the left you can see my
belly sticking out because interestingly
in that photograph I don't have much
visceral fat but what I do have is a lot
of influence from the former visceral
fat that weakened my gut so the dad bod
is really weakness where your muscles in
your anterior party abdomen can't even
hold your guts in so where you do do a
surgical procedure remove that visceral
fat right away your guts still would be
pushing out because your muscles can't
hold it in so that second image shows my
abdom has become much flatter so for the
point of the audience listening you know
really look at what really matters
inside of your body it's not just losing
weight like Joshua said you could do
that chopping off a particular limb but
you want to jettison this stuff that's
harmful to you and hold on the stuff
that's beneficial and so visceral fat is
bad fat but there's also good fat which
is
um
superficial subcutaneous fat so a little
layer of fat uh just on the outside
we've seen in studies is very protective
um and another good fat is brown adipose
tissue we call it brown fat and that one
comes from cold showers and lifestyle
can can help to increase that so you
know the the opportunity to educate you
know the minimalist podcast audience and
and have people understand that not all
fat is the same not all weight is the
same you know you maybe you're gaining
weight but you're gaining good tissue
maybe you're losing weight but you're
losing bad tissue and that's where the
MRI I think is so helpful I think that
measurements aren't helpful if we're
measuring the wrong thing if we simply
are looking at weight it doesn't tell me
the full picture weight of what because
I first heard about you from we were
talking about Dr Anthony chafee and uh I
guess on certain and body mass indexes
he might be considered obese because
we're measuring it the wrong way now he
probably has eight percent body fat or
and he's a really big athletic guy but
if you just measure weight it's not
really telling you the full picture yeah
that is such a great uh point and so you
know one of the things that uh is
impressive about there are many things
impressed about our country is uh uh
American Commerce and uh maybe we could
get into that that's really interesting
is good analogy for biology to
understand Medical Health what's going
on in in Corporate America I'd love to
get back to Dave's question here
directly so what he's saying here is hey
look I weigh 132 pounds and I can't
believe that in my mid-40s I need to be
below 130 pounds and the fascinating
thing is I see a lot of people in their
30s and 40s when their their body starts
to change in interesting ways it's many
years of of accumulating visceral fat
and now all of a sudden I feel like oh I
I I'm like him he's like I've even
though I'm within this healthy limit I
have a fat face or I have a protruding
stomach and you see that in your images
that you've shown here but you've also
shown that it's reversible up on the
screen here we have this picture of Dr
Sean I hope I can look that great
tomorrow
at age 42 but holy moly man
um so this is you I guess a couple years
ago approaching age 60 at that point and
looked like a 21 year old athlete but
the good news is you didn't always look
like this way you didn't always walk
around looking like Michael Phelps and
that's clear in the previous picture
here so maybe we can give Dave some hope
here yeah so one of the things I would
tell Dave to do as my favorite form of
exercise is uh is what we've done
ancestral ancestrally for four million
years the two things that kept our uh
keep kept individuals in the species the
longest and also equated to the best
quality of life were two things and that
is fighting and sprinting but fighting
is something hard to really Advocate as
a position you know I we joked within my
our startup that we can have clients go
to a bar and get in a fight and actually
help to Autumn eyes them but we we
stayed away from that and you can
exercise in a very intense manner but
the second thing is something every you
know everybody listening could consider
doing that is sprinting so sprinting
when you think about it is a perfect
minimalist activity so instead of doing
the more maximal kind of activity where
you're doing long distance running I
started embracing the age of 48
sprinting and so sprinting will help
Dave and anybody listening uh that's in
their 30s and 40s who wants to jettison
some some of this excess lifestyle that
they've accumulated excess bad fat
visceral fat if you sprint that will
happen the fastest and the easiest and
the reason is when you sprint it
releases uh a messaging molecule called
myokines and another uh messaging
molecule called lacfy which is a
combination between lactate and
phenolaline and I hope that's the last
time I have to say that because that's a
tough word but Lac fee is the easiest
easier way to express it and
interestingly they looked at a study 10
different forms of exercise and they
studied these different forms of
exercise for which produces the most Lac
fee and right at the top was sprinting
the next one below it was weight lifting
resistance training and at the bottom of
the 10 forms of exercise was distance
running so sprinting seconds of maximum
intensity exercise is really the key for
Dave and other people that want to burn
bad fat and at the same time build
muscle so nothing burns more fat bad fat
and nothing puts on more beneficial uh
you know minimalist type of muscle than
sprinting I hope you enjoyed that
highlight from the minimalist private
podcast if you did and you'd like to
dive deep into full episodes of the
private podcast head on over to patreon
just click the link down in the
description the private podcast keeps
our YouTube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck but if you're not
ready for that just yet head on over to
this video on our YouTube channel
[Music]
foreign